كشف دبلوماسيون اوروبي للعربيه ان السفير
الاتحاد الاوروبي في الخرطوم بخير وان
الاعتداء الذي استهدف مقر اقامته في
العاصمه السودانيه اساء اصاب مبنى المقر
الرسمي وكان ممثل السياسه الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي وزير قال ان السفير
الاتحاد في السودان تعرض لاعتداء في مقر
اقامته من دون ذكر تفاصيل حول طبيعه
الاعتداء او المهاجمين المحتملين واضاف
بريال عبر حسابه على تويتر ان الاعتداء
يشكل انتهاكا صارخا لاتفاقيه فيينا مشيرا
الى ان امن المنشات والموظفين
الدبلوماسيين مسؤوليه اساسيه للسلطات
السودانيه والتزام بموجب القانون الدولي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات